do you think people that are starting
comedy Now
are is it going to be a completely
different world where I I tendency now
people that are starting are going to
have to go to the internet and and
almost the same way that you were taking
a beating at open mics and things like
that they're almost gonna have to take a
beating online in front of a digital
audience to build their thing because
the the mainstream or the Legacy
industry seems to of Comedy seems to be
dying so even though they'll be getting
good at stand up on the side if they
don't have other components what what do
you mean by the mainstream of comedies
meaning that the idea of moving to New
York or LA and doing 20 sets a week and
then getting the Montreal Comedy
Festival and then getting the the booker
at the club to see one like you and then
getting a special on HBO all that seems
to be dying I know so many people with
our specials and nobody's watching them
right or so many people with late night
TV shows like they're hosting them and
no one cares yeah that's true and and
they're not making that much money and
it seems to be a smaller and smaller
circle of people that this is mattering
to every day the internet's expanding it
seems to be getting bigger and bigger
and the people that have a platform
online a digital platform seem to be
getting more and more attention so to me
isn't there an inevitable shift coming
to where Comics really are just gonna
have to compete did usually I think the
digital aspect of it is the best way to
promote themselves for sure whether it's
through putting their stuff online on a
YouTube or a rumble or Instagram or
whatever they're doing like we're
together on your own getter that's a
news story Chinese Communist party now I
believe yeah why are you it's a news
story that you're on getter well the new
story is they're they're [ __ ] amount
of people that signed up increased by
1150 or something yeah you have like 20
you have like nine million followers on
getter yeah it's not real though is it
because Canada doesn't even have nine
million people no really yeah it's it's
very it's so they're [ __ ] with that
this is where the [ __ ] is they take
all my Twitter followers so I my Twitter
follows like 7.8 million yeah and then
they Port those over so I started out
with 7.8 million oh so whatever I have
now if I have eight it's like really I
have 200 000. so getter yes
as they say and every time I post on
Twitter it posts automatically on getter
oh interesting yeah like it's
automatically done so it's just
harvesting your tweets and I don't know
how to get off like if I get off again I
don't have to you you have to I can you
have to sit down with Marjorie Taylor
green personally and she's got to tell
me all about what's in the basement
she's gotta take you down the rabbit
hole then you come out the other side of
getter but yeah it seems to me that like
the business is kind of dying I don't
think it is you don't think it is no no
I disagree I prove it is no no no that
aspect of the business as far as like
Montreal Comedy Festival and stuff like
that being beneficial that's true that's
dying right but podcasts have taken
their place right comedians now like
Brian Simpson who's got his newest
Netflix one of the best yeah he's
working with me this weekend he's one of
the best I love him to death and he now
that he has this huge Netflix special
that killed and he's been on my podcast
a couple of times he's got a career
right he's killing it right he will
continue to kill it yeah so this is
where the the but he's not as big as
Rambo
so my point is that who's that Rambo's a
Minecraft streamer Joe stop pretending
you don't know who he is is that real
yeah he's a Minecraft streamer my point
is that
things are moving quick we can't compare
ourselves to Minecraft I understand that
but I'm just saying yes we can
I was in the news and Doctor disrespect
has a book Mr Beast has a burger well Mr
Beast deserves a burger he's a brilliant
guy is he good it's a great show yeah he
does he does he's a Visionary guy it's a
smart thing that he does he spends a
shitload of money on his show well
that's what I mean these are the new
stars well that's just in that world
those are the new stars in terms of like
that would he would be a reality TV star
like 10 years ago for sure now he's a
YouTube Star but now he's his own
[ __ ] boss and he's doing it the right
way which is why it's so successful the
same thing with your podcast imagine a
world where an executive bankrolls your
podcast and says oh are you going to sit
together with your friend Ben and you're
gonna wear cop sunglasses yeah and
you're going to talk [ __ ] about the
whole world yeah what are you talking
about yeah you want me to pay for that I
can think of several Executives that
would fund it but they're all disgraced
Angelo mazzillo at Country ride dick
fold at Lehman Brothers exactly yeah no
for sure the world has changed but there
are new avenues that are available right
but the world of Comedy remains in clubs
like you yeah that is true you might be
able to get on stage again and we both
yeah that is the most important one of
the most important things yes it's like
I'm not giving that up like stand up no
one's [ __ ] awesome and yes that is
always going to be a thing that I like
to see and it's always going to be a
thing that I like to do and it's always
going to be a thing where people want to
go see a comic they want to go live it's
a fun thing to do don't you want to get
to the point where people know you so
well from the internet that when you get
on stage they just clap for 45 minutes
you don't even have to write material
and then you can just leave you can kind
of wave like Princess Diana used to do I
don't think it happens I don't think you
ever get that of course not I feel the
heat after about 15 minutes of course I
know of course you do I I get nervous as
soon as I walk on stage I get the mic I
go uh no it's the biggest high you ever
have it's the best thing it's the best
art form it's also the best thing for
the audience like in terms of like it's
the most of an audience member yeah I
love watching someone kill it's fun
that's right when I laugh hard like I'm
laughing hard someone killing but you're
also from a generation of people that
leaves their house that's true there's a
whole generation of people that are
scared to leave the room well let alone
the house my audience
I'll quit you have to keep evolving you
should be on Twitch you should be
streaming I'm on Spotify you're a young
man my Evolution you can keep going
where's my deal what did they tell us
[ __ ] off for the ninth time oh because
they're telling you I could attack the
CEO I said he was a pedophile it was a
joke that's not real no one can have fun
anymore I think he said I'm a pedophile
too yeah I don't know if I did that but
I said that the CEO
was uh something or rather but then so
he's mad at you no he's not mad but
apparently because they have you they
don't need me yeah because we have
overlap and they're still going by they
should get you they're still going by
the old numbers that say that this
Show's bigger than mine those are the
old numbers this last week this Show's
not even on YouTube anymore I keep
telling them it's true it's not even on
YouTube they go oh no it doesn't matter
we have the internals in your bed
honestly the the beautiful thing about
Spotify has been the lack of censorship
and the lack of fear of having episodes
pulled and all that [ __ ] Spotify has
been amazing and in the beginning people
thought they were going to be worse than
YouTube they've actually conversely been
so much better yeah they've been so much
better I think that's just because
people are always they tear they hate
change they hate any kind of like news
that's right thing that's happening and
you know also it's like they hate they
hate someone doing well so someone gets
something crazy deal and they're making
all this money like oh it sucks now I
used to watch now I hate it yeah it's
[ __ ] it's the worst she's sold out
normal it's normal right so and also in
the beginning I did lose a lot we lost
like 50 percent of our audience like
almost right away yeah Jamie was in a
frothy Panic really look at him well
he's got so many other opportunities
frothy Panic yeah
um but a year later we've got as much if
not more we have more now right and it's
better it's bigger than it's ever been
it just it just had to like this is just
what happens immediately but I was like
good let me be 10 less famous right
it'll be happy for 25. give me 25 less
Fame yeah and more money well that's not
the way it's worked out that well that's
funny you're like let's be a little less
controversial a little less famous and
then on the other side of it you have
fauci trying to drone you outside of
your house